one time she was laughing at our living
room and she peed her pants
thank you
Jenna Bush hager's daughter trolls her
hard live on TV that's a headline for me
on Tuesday Jenna's daughter Mila stopped
by today with Hoda and Jenna to surprise
her mom and the nine-year-old throws
some cute sass right from the jump
what's your name yeah this is
hey how are you good are you exactly
like your mom no no you're different how
are you different little missy because
I'm better
dude yeah Mila may have taken a dig at
her mom there but she also kept it sweet
talking about Jenna's relationship with
her co-host
Mila asked her if she goes is Hoda your
best friend and I said she's one of my
best friends how could you tell
because you guys are always together
that's true I know people don't are like
okay you know the Today Show family like
can it really be like that but it is and
I just feel so grateful because it makes
going to work such a joy that these
people are some of my very best friends
but back to Mila you know when I love
her the most meal when she's laughing
do you know that kind when she does that
yeah yeah sometimes she was laughing at
our living room and she peed her pants
thank you so is it so did you laugh so
hard too isn't she the funniest yeah get
ready cause Mila throws her mom under
the bus not once but twice I love her so
much but it's time for her to go because
if she's already dropped one truth bomb
no I like him you know there's much
coming here I think Hoda's trying to get
the truth bombs out but no more is that
the last one nope okay no no one little
one just one tiny one she never wears
underwear
did she just say what we think she just
said she never wears underwear yep she
sure did
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it's the look on Jenna's face for us I
mean look Jenna puts her heart on the
table like right here this is where it
rests so anyone who watches this show is
gonna is gonna see the real deal Jenna
who shares Mila as well as
seven-year-old daughter Poppy and
three-year-old son Hal with her husband
Henry Hager has been candid with E.T in
the past about The Not So Glam side of
Parenthood when turn spring in New York
it is a magical time my daughter
actually had an incident where she
popped a squat in the park so that was a
memory I don't know if it was a favorite
it was probably a least favorite and
she's opened up about raising her kiddos
with her today show Family by her side
it's really fun find a colleague to get
you
today so it's cliche to say it's like a
family but I can ask them advice we've
been talking a lot about sleeping but I
can also ask them about work I'm like
what a cool what a cool place to work
[Music]
thank you